what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season four episode
two today John how's it going I'm good
how are you sir I'm doing well coral
pumps part dos hope we check in with the
actual benign today leave a like be very
much appreciated as always thanks to all
who support us on our patreon you can
catch the full length Reaction watch the
lungs where you sync up with your own
copy of Brooklyn Nine-Nine over there we
also cover several shows over there
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch alongs included lastly the
team at prepper hope you did a good job
on any of this down if there's anything
about the edit you guys don't like blame
them and only them and never us all
right let's do it
any idea why Marshall Haas called the
special meeting I don't know do you
think she saw the video we put on the
internet to lure Jimmy figgas down here
corn dog puned by go-kart it's pwned but
that was really adorable so how's it
going keep it low Prof no contact with
Brooklyn no one's questioned our
identities definitely staying off the
net right Greg right
so nobody's gonna ask me how I'm doing
oh I didn't think this was a personal
conversation it's not turned background
movie
this is official business I was just
testing you because Greg is the kind of
person who cares about his friends and
I met someone okay and um I mean it's
not my husband I mean nothing's happened
yet but my entire body is on fire he's
Cuban is this still official business of
course it is you ain't got your ring
if Larry were married and everything was
fine and I mean honestly everything is
totally fine sure but he knew that one
night
person could give him everything he
needed for the rest of his life
will you do it yes yes
Larry has needs deserves to have those
needs
meant
Greg you're really great at being
Undercover
the Marshall is letting me write a
one-page letter to Jake which she will
read to him and then set on fire so
anything you guys want me to write you
have to tell Jake about my new son
nicolash that he's four years old and I
love him so much Rosa anything you want
to tell Jake yeah tell him I said damn
we're getting a new captain again
Hello Larry it's your neighbor Greg
thinking of getting one of course that's
a totally normal thing to do in 100
degree weather come on in
your body will work harder to cool
itself down men with a thick New Jersey
accent called The Fun Zone asking to
meet the guys from the corn dog video I
think this is coming to kill us
we should call the 99 Rebecca oh
absolutely not that might alert the
marshals we can dig figures and his men
down on our own what okay let's go arm
up the biggest hits no idea what's about
to hit him also it probably goes without
saying but it's chill to whiz in this
thing
you can if you want I haven't been if
you haven't have you I haven't have you
we'll have to bribe the gun store owner
so he doesn't run our names but we don't
have any money
I'm the bribe aren't I you're not the
bride why what's wrong with my body
actually I borrowed three thousand
dollars for my walking group friend Ruth
Ruth I'm gonna be straight with you Ruth
I see a pair of thick weighty breasts
and all logic flies out the window
heterosexual you is such a dog
thick and weighty eight handguns couple
of shotguns and I don't know three more
handguns can I see some ID yes of course
of course ah it's Florida well they
record
it's America give him the gun I don't
need your ID Federal database is done
anyway wink wink ah so how do you like
your ammo exactly
please give him a warm welcome
Hey guys uh I'm captain Stanley I love
this guy cam Commander Ken Marino you
weren't sweatpants no oh yes yes I am I
um had some hot cocoa this morning and I
totally biffed it I like this guy
I had an appointment at my dermatologist
at 402 7th Avenue but I went to 204 7th
Avenue by mistake it's like numbers are
so crazy am I right amen not really
anyway
spook the Kingpin he darts for the front
door trips shoots himself in the stomach
accidentally and then after that
everybody pretty much surrendered very
quickly and they made me a captain about
a week later
like wasn't there like an interview
where they they met you and
heard you speak
what I need as an assistant of my own
just to do my paperwork and all my other
work work is the worst I get it oh hire
whoever you want
we have a dangerous task ahead of us
wait I thought you said we didn't need
backup are you worried do we need to
call the 99 no no no no no no we have
the drop on figures we're fully armed up
and we have plenty of time to lay a trap
well okay then see you around Coral
Palms a trape say you never drive
through Vape station adios weird Juggalo
encampment bye-bye slightly excused stop
sign oh God for running a stop sign we
just passed someone driving with both
feet out the window just be cool Larry
gentlemen I am going to need to see your
license and registrations Jerry I'm
talking about the pile of guns in the
bucket of bullets
sure sure I made you both to step out of
the vehicle did anything to put in the
trunk did you I am sorry about the delay
we are overwhelmed here today
we hired our first woman so of course
you need your own bathroom and the shirt
don't fit right in both chaos oh my God
all right women
I think we all agree that CJ is to put
it mildly not very impressive I watched
him try to close the blinds in his
office for 40 minutes he finally just
gave up and changed his pants with the
windows wide open
hey guys I'm Emily Gina's assistant wait
she actually got that oh wait she
actually got that sorry I'm under strict
orders from Gina to Maki whenever I see
an opening follow me please
Rosa Dare To Dream what do you want for
him to be gone you want that more than
you want walls around your desk so
Hitchcock can't stare you with this big
old google eyes anymore CJ stays I love
that guy that's not fair
I agree with Amy that CJ is totally
unqualified and a disaster for the
precinct and I would really love a
treadmill desk so I can hit my cardio
targets done yes dream big oh looks like
you're all alone
um can you go ahead and show her out
right this way please and can I validate
your parking I work here
you can see I know you boys around the
level okay uh question two what do you
hunt
uh you said you had somewhere important
to go so where exactly is that
oh boy dinner date dinner date that's
no one has ever beaten the Newlywed Game
no one
hey Diaz
right the walls
ring bell
can I help you I need the crime stats
from last month fine she's got such a
tan
some people huh hey I'm up to 20 000
steps seriously Boyle oh you don't care
about my health you don't care if an e
collage grows up without a papa you want
me to die honestly a little
hurts you could die on a treadmill DJ
and Gina just buy them off but we don't
need them because we've got you okay
Terry what'd you get what'd you get
lifetime yogurt what did he give you he
gave me the ability to continue to serve
this community unencumbered by
unnecessary oversight now I really have
to what did he give you he gave me a
yogurt friend yes
right next to my desk I'm only a man I'm
sending this letter with or without your
signature
enjoy your blood yogurt blickert
yo platelets
I'm not really Greg and that's not Larry
we're Captain Raymond Holt and detective
Jake Peralta of the in white you're
confessing to the enemy we're in witness
protection and that is the full truth
good one that's a good one just call the
U.S Marshal who handles our case she'll
explain everything she
uh-huh right okay we'll do
well it's a guy and he says he's never
heard to be the one again that's
impossible listen for yourself hello
it's Vegas oh
knew it see talking to the enemy sounds
like Eric Roberts
jailbreak and how do you propose to pull
that off by using this ragtag team of
inmates our very own
Suicide Squad all right let's rally
I have a glass eye glass eye how about
you sir I mean I've been arrested for a
lot of different stuff uh public
urination urinating on private property
here at 8 and 25 feet from a school year
oh I'm Tito I'm great at spoken meth
it's Norton meth
and I haven't spoken to my daughter in a
couple of years that's so sad okay so
find something for Tito Tito and
apparently they also received hundreds
of others in support of CJ yeah Emily
and I sent those in so Emily what was
that burn I had you write down for Amy
it's a school desk hey Amy what did one
graphing calculator say to the other one
Amy colon what Gina colon why does this
said lady
hey you know what
well the only reason we're killing it is
because Captain Holt never let us be
satisfied with ourselves he always
inspired us to work harder and smarter
you'd be ashamed of us Amy wait
it's a good stunt Tuesday at five it's
Tanya time well there he goes oh no okay
now I gotta get rid of the other Deputy
glass eye you're up
oh
it's drier than I would have thought did
I want it to be wet Jake I'm sorry I was
holding an eyeball in my hand no big
deal here we go
oh great shot Sheriff I'm gonna go get a
mop
great now we stage a fight the sheriff
comes in to break it up we take him down
foreign
kiss yeah I can't stay mad at you
oh stop it what are you doing it's 2016
man this is on you
I returned my yogurt fridge I gave my
treadmill desk back I took down my desk
walls and I have agreed to fire my
assistant assistant Dana Dana who's Dana
Emily had a lot on her plate
make tough choices tell people no
sometimes if that's what you guys want
good talk my door is always open except
when it's closed but you can open it
when it's closed
[Laughter]
it's time to call the Nine-Nine
absolutely not what is going on with you
nothing I just think that we can do it
alone sir
we just shared one of the longest kisses
of my life I think we can be honest with
each other
the 99 bailed me out once before when I
was taken hostage by Bob a man I had put
my trust in like a fool I don't want
them to rescue me again it's
embarrassing I need to clean up my own
mess Pride there's nothing wrong with
asking for help from people that care
about you this is Sergeant Terry
Jeffords
oh there's an urgent situation and we
need 72 hours off to go to Florida now I
can't say why absolutely not ugh someone
once told me that being a captain means
telling people no I kind of feel like
this is my fault I kind of feel like
this is my fault not how Emily from your
lawn
wow wow I hope the whole season takes
place at the coral Palms yes just always
cutting back and forth that's fun that
was fun it's kind of Captain John would
be that's right whatever you need or not
you let me know and I'll and I'll figure
it out just yeah sure whatever keep
everyone happy and I think John would be
a great Captain thank you John captains
everything here and I think you're being
an amazing captain in real life it was
Captain of a police station take it away
John I love the way Captain this review
I'm loving this I like this art quite a
bit I know we'll get back to the point
where everyone's back in the 99 and I'm
looking forward to that as well but
right now I am quite enjoying the fact
that this is at least developing into a
few episodes worth of an arc you know I
like especially here like the first
episode like we said was was amazingly
one of the most hilarious ones but you
know I like the change of scenery I love
the witness protection story identities
they gotta go with and here then getting
the back and forth to kooky new captain
plus everything going on with them
having this jailbreak I was like this is
a lovely blend of tones and settings and
uh you know guest actors and whatnot so
uh I'm really looking forward to Coral
Palms part three uh what did you think
Maestro yeah it was a really fun episode
I loved everything at the Brooklyn
Nine-Nine station as well yeah
um the new captain is really funny I
like that type of behavior because
there's always something kind of dumb
about the new captains whether it be uh
ego trying to prove themselves but I
like this kind of slackerish sort of
Captain I think is a really funny bit to
do and the hijinks of what everyone was
requesting I thought was very amusing in
the clever turn of them
wanting to do the right thing and not
take advantage of that completely
backfires them in the end I think is
actually really cleverly written thing
so and by the way they have a walking
desks uh they like fold out treadmills
that you that people use that one they
have standing desks and it's pretty cool
they're not too expensive actually but
they would come in handy for walking
steps instead of having to do this big
elaborate thing but uh uh
well Boyle was doing putting like a
legit standing desk on top of a real
treadmill yeah yeah now you can actually
have like a little a real small walking
treadmill to get those steps in by the
way just a little tip tidbit for you
guys and
um so we got that going but and
everything the coral Palms that was
really funny as well I mean Maya Rudolph
was all right last episode but I like
this weird progression that you have of
the Marshall sounds like we're actually
going to finally see Vegas and I'm
looking forward to seeing who that guest
star is you're guessing Eric Roberts I'm
guessing uh Charlie day so we'll see
which one it's gonna be by the end
definitely Charlie day and you know that
whole thing with hold having a difficult
time allowing people in to help him it
can be a very relatable subject for some
people and
not me I don't like to do anything and I
prefer asking people for help for
everything and I'd rather just rely on
others instead of myself I'm just that
kind of guy I have no Independence so I
don't really get where holes coming from
but I like it from an observational
angle and then them also getting to be
the criminals I think it's a neat deep
Prospect ever since we had Jason
manzukas come in here you know that was
and like they've had the undercover
stuff before but now we're seeing
characters really really getting to see
the other side because even though it
was that line that Andy Samberg had that
was really funny of like this is what
they all think when talking about the
bad guys
like well that is kind of the journey
that you're going on and in a weird sort
of way being real fugitives now going
from Witness Protection Program to a
fugitive story I think they're having a
lot of fun with this story arc and it
has been very enjoyable how they're
handling it so yeah bringing some style
substance and some character development
along the way killing it Stephanie
Beatrice got a new kind of makeup face
look going on here makeover and season
four makeover we have
um uh Marissa malio tell me Melissa
famero uh she is not pregnant anymore
you can tell truly tell Shane frankly
not pregnant anymore she looks great
super hot Gina was hilarious this
episode I thought Gina was really funny
I thought this episode was fun fun super
super fun stuff for fun season four fun
for sure hope they keep her assistant
too good good job on on expanding the
Gina lore yeah you dated that girl once
didn't you that's right Emily the
assistant
no the actual actress and you date her
yes definitely her too
I dated her while she was prepping for
this it was kind of like dating two
people what was it like uh you know it
was kind of like
it's just the best you know like I love
living with uh aspiring actors who you
know just are all about the craft and uh
you never know when you're uh being told
the truth or when you're witnessing a
sincere emotion because they're just
that good at warping in and out of uh
chameleon-like States you know
really chameleon-like States yeah sure
sounds like a good time that was great
times the best time I miss it and I cry
every night for not being in that
position
oh for not being in that position no not
anymore
not dating the the the actress who plays
Emily the assistant on Brooklyn
Nine-Nine
well sounds like that you actually
really care about people and you know
definitely
um
or someone who can miss those that you
want to share an experience with
no I'm just a closed off sociopathic
person now oh are you yeah I don't have
attachments to anybody all right we'll
bring that energy to the patron of the
day
Brian Perry I don't care about you you
affect me in no way I can't do it I
can't do it I care to I tried do you're
right yes and I care too much and Brian
I care that you're here we are happy
every month to read off your name to
come up with some in fact let's look up
a famous criminal named Brian
crime is what I'm searching
Brian Housey was freed from prison
that's good cool awesome spent 19 years
in prison yeah and uh and two heinous
Child Murders hey look at that
um but they were committed in 1905
another Mass you're innocent Brian it's
good days for you free hallelujah we're
gonna throw you a party pop the
champagne because you have you got your
life back today yeah definitely after so
many years of paying for somebody else's
consequences you know well it's not it's
actually Byron not Brian
well we dodged a bullet there Brian
you're the only person of your name
Google brings up only Byron's which is
great unless you spelled your name wrong
and we've been saying it wrong because
you spelled it wrong this whole time
then I would feel pretty bad about all
this oh man as long as a single Brian
out there
um man your your folks got very original
or you if you named yourself got very
original naming yourself Hosea Brian's
Evans okay who lives at
um well it's public information uh five
Virginia Street St Paul sure uh date of
birth uh 1996. oh good oh that would
make him around like 26 years old and
um oh well felony and warrants for
burglary okay all right yeah we should
arrest this guy you're a burglar we're
gonna come find you yeah
Brian
and we'll we'll you know shout out go
the way you're hoping yeah absolutely
this is I scripted this all out of my
mind I was like this couldn't have
gotten better and I think Brian agrees
with me
[Music]